hey guys i'm ryan right and alyssa be
crazy and I'm tired holy crap sorry if I
look tired today I don't know why I'm
really tired it's been a draining day I
think for everybody it has been and you
know what I mean draining day come on
think you set me up for it I did I uh
really no miss Italy okay so we're gonna
watch a trailer today for a movie called
Veronica that's where the king veronika
decides to die I have not heard of this
is new information baby baby there's a
movie with a title in your name it's
called veronika decides to die but I
don't want you to die oh she's not gonna
die some sexual content oh hell usually
where am I a privately funded
psychiatric facility next you're gonna
take good care of you our director dr.
Blake has taken special interest in your
case it may only be a matter you have
very unorthodox methods dr. Blake
families of other patients who have
complained we're torturing the dying
girl making will recover her will to
live all in the name of racer so I'm
gonna die after all I can show it a
spotlight on the unusual activities
taking place up absolutely nothing to
time without the chamber board to be the
same as everybody else oh my god
your son you may be feeling better what
okay i guess that he's doing these
experiments on people it kind of looks
poorly made I think they didn't give us
enough to go off of here's the here's
the thing it seems like one of those
shows or movies that seem like they
could be really good and have a lot of
potential but nobody will watch it like
in the beginning cougar town it's a
great show nobody watches equis at the
mean late that that is just a weird name
don't don't don't now you got to cougar
tear all this is it that's a great joke
bad name this could be a great movie
with a bad knee maybe but the this at
the end of the day to me it doesn't look
like it was made all that well like I
know it's just a trailer could be a
poorly cut trailer I feel like I'm here
in the directory go action now cut I
feel like the behind the scenes too much
of what's going on it could just be the
trailer though because if you look at
the past they would have put so much you
know time and money into this project if
it had a you know you're insane about
the caf well you have to have some kind
of something behind just cuz it's a good
cast of doesn't mean it's gonna be your
good fair but they won't because you
know put together an amazing cast and
skimp on editing it doesn't work like
that ah it does it not I don't know you
need to watch more movies I know I'm a
Disney child yeah I don't buy more I
mean sarah michelle gellar looks like
she's trying really hard though i don't
believe her uh is her character actually
psychotic do we know that no II don't
I'm pleased to actually be psychotic it
more well no matter what she's doing it
looks like she's trying I feel like
she's playing an emotion I don't feel
like she's really living the role yeah
but do you actually feel that way about
Sarah Michelle Gellar or her roles like
are their roles of her that you've
actually liked the only thing s are
almost Buffy and I bought her in that
okay fair enough wait more that is Sarah
Michelle Gellar who's that
sir Sir sabrina the teenage witch
melissa heart I don't know Alyssa why
are you defending this damn movie so
much nothing but sending it I'm just
saying like it looks like it could have
potential it looks like the air has
potential but they ruined it trailer
yeah yeah it's are on the same page
change the name first then get back to
us cos yes it's a weird name you don't
just decide you don't wake up one day
and be like I'm gonna die today like if
you don't cut of an intrigue in my
opinion we have a good debate going I
think the title veronika decides to die
sounds cheesy and Mary b-movie like but
it does make me kind of go why did she
decide to die what's happening hey like
it does make me think that I think
you're clever Hollywood cheese Hollywood
cheese yeah Hollywood cheese cheese
isn't that delicious yeah well you know
what sometimes you melt it too much and
then you burn it a little bit no that's
what happened with the cheese in this
movie on dude this doesn't look like
fondue quality I don't know the work
that goes into making fondues you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects make sure to check
out Alyssa be crazies channel vlogs and
challenges and all that fun tube stuff
so much fun mmm send me challenges
challenge host you'll take on any
challenge asia be very careful with what
you say but i will consider all
challenges she means that I do I really
do there some we did request yeah
actually I need challenges right now
because I'm about to do a whole bunch
plus the ghost pepper shut yo face I
wasn't doing it the look that you got
any way reduced rate of shout outs again
in the new year so go to facebook.com
slash the real rejection outs to get a
shout just say something actually
interesting and hopefully try and make
him laugh that's like a shirt far away
if you laughs out loud it's something
actually funny yeah cuz I never left